vous avez été chroniqueur d'on n'est pas
couché de 2007 à 2011 en compagnie
d'eric zemmour
on va revoir votre style à tous les deux
et juste après ce sera la séquence
fensch puisque vous nous avez demandé
quelque chose votre question vous allez
vous même la pause et mai sont en gros
est ce que vous devez continuer
travailler à travailler de travailler
avec eric zemmour juste regarder le
style de lady gaga c'est votre nom
d'artiste est ce que vous vous répétez
beaucoup dans les chansons d'un quart
d'heure que je jure sur la tête de ma
mère que c'est à 0 que c'est pas un
sketch de jonathan lambert
oui c'est sûr ça dit oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh c'est du banat bombe à la bombe
wolfsburg lady gaga mika ci serait
plutôt lady globaux qui arrive
aujourd'hui c'est que c'est du n'importe
quoi c'est à quoi tout le monde se prend
pour un chanteur un acteur un hacker
alors il ya michel onfray qui s'en est
pris au patron de lci ce week end et
eric zemmour céret fait beaucoup parler
lui en ce moment et eric naulleau
vous allez nous dire quel est votre
sentiment voilà où vous en êtes
actuellement c'est vrai que vous avez
une petite passe d'armes avec lui sur
paris première la semaine dernière suite
à ses propos vous allez nous parler de
tout ça et vous avez donc poser votre
question
eric vous pouvez à poser maintenant ou
bien vous pouvez vous pouvez la pause et
après la pub c'est vrai mais vraiment il
va avoir besoin de vous chers
téléspectateurs vraiment eric c'est un
beau cadeau que vous nous faites et
c'est un beau geste en soit la chose dit
ça m'intéresse d'avoir l'avis des uns et
les autres
c'est vraiment la question et du public
au sujet nous dire vous aussi vous vous
en êtes actuellement dans votre tête
eric naulleau merci d'être avec nous et
eric naulleau on l'a dit si vous nous
rejoignez vous travaillez avec eric
zemmour depuis 2007 2007 jean n'est pas
couché sans j'interroge après vous avez
fait zemmour et naulleau en 2000 c'était
en 2011 depuis 2011 c'est eric voilà va
très bien et là une semaine dernière
c'est elle d'ailleurs le retour de
l'émission zemmour et naulleau sur paris
première vous aviez d'ailleurs dit tout
ce que vous pensiez tout bas à propos
d'eric zemmour
regardez juste le tac d'eric naulleau et
eric zemmour est juste après eric vous
allez poser votre question aux
téléspectateurs et aux chroniqueurs
c'est parti tout est question de limites
pour moi tu as franchi les limites sur
des thèmes qui me sont chers la
comparaison entre le nazisme et l'islam
je peux pas tolérer ça d'abord parce que
je me réclame delà de la gauche anti
totalitaire
est ce que tu dis c'est une insulte
envers tous les musulmans de france dont
la plupart quand même vivre paisiblement
c'est une insulte envers tous ceux qui
soit personnellement soit à travers la
famille ont subi le nazisme
on peut pas comparer une religion avec
les excès de cette religion qui
s'appelle l'islamisme quand tu mets un
signe d'égalité entre nazisme et islam
je trouve ça inqualifiable et je trouve
ça indigne
alors j'ai dit beaucoup de choses cette
danse est extrême non mais c'est une
question qui est très importante pour
moi c'est pas
c'est pas choisir un nouveau slip de
bain cccv 10 et il ya douze ans de
compagnonnage avec ces mots moi j'ai
beaucoup réfléchi à cette question je le
dirai tout à l'heure où j'en suis de ma
réflexion bien sûr mais on me pose
beaucoup cette question beaucoup de gens
estiment que zemmour a franchi une
limite et que désormais il est
infréquentable et comme c'est moi qui le
fréquentent le plus peut-être au monde
puisque les voiles alors je vais je vous
en parle après avec vous mais c'est vrai
que vous avez toujours dit ce que vous
avez c'est être le contradicteur et que
vous pensez que c'est alors on va vous
allez avoir l'avis des téléspectateurs
et la vie des chroniqueurs géraldine
maillet qu'est ce que vous dites moi je
pense que tu dois continuer à travailler
avec eric vous avez vos pancartes oui
non maison qu'il doit continuer à
travailler avec eric zemmour et eric
naulleau
vous pourrez répondre vous aussi c'est
important votre avis compte énormément
alors oui toujours dit que tu discuter
avec tout le monde tu as toujours dit
qu'ils n'avaient pas de liste noire et
que si jamais puisque leurs assises ou
l'islamophobie est un est un est un
délit il doit être condamné par la
justice mais pas par toi toi tu dois
être un contradicteur tu dois t'opposer
bec et ongles à ses idées à son
idéologie assez fixe est insupportable
et indigne moi je pense que tu dois
travailler avec lui de la même manière
que tu avais écrit un livre avec soral à
une époque qui lui même a été socialiste
avait rencontré non mais il avait quand
même signé un livre abysses avec alain
soral contre eux soient exacts avec j'ai
des choses parce que c'est on passe de
100 pages la semaine sur la gueule quand
j'entends un livre avec soral c'est
contre sera assez d'accord avec vous et
rythmé certes mais ton nom était quand
même content efforts éditorialement
parlant donc moi je pense que tu dois
continuer coûte que coûte
de la même manière qu'à une époque le
front national était stigmatisé on
voulait pas débattre avec notre voie
aujourd'hui s'appelle le rassemblement
national
il faut condamner ses idées il faut
justement en parler mais c'est pas en
les stigmatisant la mettant de côté il
faut au contraire montrer point par
point qu'ils ont tort
allez j'étais la vie de géraldine il
n'aurait bien de nom c'est mathieu et
benjamins je vais avoir l'avis de
mathieu qui dit non pourquoi
non j'ai dit non parce que moi je ne
crois je ne pardonne pas tous au nom de
la liberté d'expression c'est quelque
chose qui commence à m'agacer
je prends un exemple tout bête mais mais
mais dieudonné et est condamné et avec
juste raison lorsqu'il tient des propos
antisémites
jamas ah bah pourquoi lorsque lorsque
eric naulleau avec par l'eczéma tient
des propos voilà contre l'islam en le
comparant au nazisme
par exemple pourquoi il est peut-être
écarté de l'antenne est pourquoi il est
pas con
année tout ça parce que dans un cas on
sait que l'autre a dérapé mais voilà
aujourd'hui on parle plus de dérapages
on parle de choses qui sont très graves
pour rester sur nos lots penser qu'ils
doivent plus travailler avec alors
pardon oui effectivement je trouve que
la question comme moody's items tu
lisais par numérique pendant 12 ans tu
as travaillé quelqu'un mais qui
malheureusement depuis un an ou deux on
l'endort on en disait depuis le livre a
vraiment dérapé aujourd'hui on est plus
dans des discussions n'est plus dans des
débats aujourd'hui une personne qui a
une idéologie qui commence à être très
nette et comment cette dangereuse
donc je pense que malgré tout ton talent
tu ne pourras pas arrivée de m contre
lui je pense qu'aujourd'hui malgré tout
tu vas tu as aussi à quelqu'un qui ne
mérite plus d'être aujourd'hui avoir la
parole parle c'est l'avis de mathieu pas
d'y révéler vous vous dites je dois
continuer à travailler
j'entends tout à fait ce que dit mathieu
effectivement c'est inqualifiable et
effectivement ça pose une vraie question
néanmoins je pense qu'on peut pas le
laisser tout seul et on ne peut pas le
laisser parler tout seul il faut qu'il y
ait une contradiction puisque de toute
façon il va parler et s'il n'a pas en
face de lui un contradicteur qui est
suffisamment fort suffisamment armé
intellectuellement pour lui opposer
point par point et à chaque fois leur
poussée dans ses retranchements à lui
dire là ce que tu racontes est
complètement déments démentiel
impossible eh ben ça veut dire qu'on lui
accorde la liberté de dire tout et
n'importe quoi sans aucun contradicteur
et moi je pense qu'il a ni à une
nécessité de lui opposer à chaque fois
point par point des réponses voulait
dire ce que tu racontes est délirant
casta niveau dit non ben moi j'aime
beaucoup et eric nous garder votre porte
le problème quand un matin avec zemmour
c'est que aussi brillant soit dans
l'émission quand il assène des bêtises
pareilles
en fait tu n'arrives pas à démonter ce
que lui veut faire passer l'épaule c'est
que son message malheureusement son
message a trop horrible passe et filtrer
les gens qui le regardent reçoivent le
message après on peut expliquer
démontrer analyser mais malheureusement
le mal est fait et pour ces raisons là
il ya des gens aujourd'hui qu'ils ne
doivent plus prendre la parole parce que
les conséquences sont tragiques et
dramatique pour le portrait paix et ben
oui mais moi je préfère moi le preuve
c'est que malheureusement cocom comme
comme tu est extrêmement brillant le
fait que tu sois en face de lui c'est
d'abord un cden du crédit dont il n'a
pas besoin
première chose et secundo
malheureusement volumen quelqu'un à ça
oui mais bon puisque même alors il n
arrive pas à démonter parce que lui il
est pas là il est pas là peuvent laisser
finir deux mondes pas et on se calme
avec mamie mais lui lui il est pas là
pour démontrer pour analyser ils
balancent des choses il sait très bien
que ce qui va balancer va faire beaucoup
de bruit et toi tu démontes pas ça tu
peux pas démonté mais on peut pas des
blagues
des montées et démontées dance et pop
j'ai démonté le mans et de logiquement
elle se servir
il habite à moi presque isabelle après
jour ajout travail parce que j'aime bien
jamais je le respecte mais l'extrait
qu'on a vu là combien en quoi tu dis il
n'arrive tu n'arrives pas à le démonter
ce qui est ce qu'il dit et par ce qu'il
a été et est parfait et c'est un
contradicteur exactement au niveau des
rixes donc est-ce qu'il doit continuer à
travailler avec terri seymour la
question est de savoir oui pour moi oui
bien sûr que oui au contraire j'ai pas
ajouter un mot maxime kenny c'est très
clair à voir c'est important oui c'est
très clair il doit continuer à
travailler avec elle et qu'eric zemmour
a été à la fois intègre et impartial
dans le débat qui était mais là et
malgré des années d'amitié
tu as eu quand même prendre le
contre-pied et dire très clairement et
afficher publiquement son désaccord avec
certaines de ses positions
je pense aussi qu'il ya besoin comme
tout le monde le dit d'un contradicteur
depuis 170 ans qu'il aurait une tribune
libre dans les médias il lui faut un
contradicteur puissant eric est le
meilleur contradicteurs aujourd'hui
alors witsel a oui moi je pense qu'il
doit arriver que évidemment continuer à
travailler comme je suis d'ailleurs même
si je vais m'attirer les foudres
je suis pour qui eric zemmour puisse
continuer à s'exprimer et qu'ils soient
condamnés quand il doit être condamné
mais qu'ils puissent s'exprimer quand il
a envie de s'exprimer voilà eric
naulleau je pensais meilleur compteur et
tandis que c'est un ami qui d'autre
qu'un ami peut le dire les choses
franchement j'en ai mais j'aimerais
savoir les les failles dans un discours
de quelqu'un ou candidat n'est pas
terminé deuxième en gras dont je suis un
fervent partisan de la méthode américain
qui dit que la liberté d'opinion été
défendues par la démocratie parle par la
convention par constante chez moi là et
que même les idées les plus extrêmes de
t'exprimer que tout le monde après +2 il
veut doter en tout ont toutes ces
régulateurs et tout ceux d'essence de
cause et on va là il faut des baptisés
les idées et les soins qu'on va voir la
vérité où ils ont actuellement c'est
très important pour nos téléspectateurs
qui régissent énormément sur ce sujet
eric naulleau doit-il continuer à
travailler avec eric zemmour c'est eric
naulleau qui nous a posé la question qui
voulez nous poser la question laurie
parce que notre eric qui se pose
beaucoup de questions voitures de la
paix sérieuses construit que tu pourras
rien contre cet argument on ne peut pas
séparer les idées des gens qui les
portent
sinon on aurait pu dire je prends un
exemple extrême volontairement on aurait
pu dire à l'époque
hitler est un garçon charmant dans la
vie mais j'aime pas ses idées ou de long
qui avait dit un jour
je n'aime pas les idées de le pen mais
j'adore la personne on peut pas séparer
les gens des idées qu'ils les portent
donc si c'est ton ami tu va accepter ses
idées et met ses idées si c'est pas ton
ami tu ouvres a précisé quand il s'agit
d'aider aussi extrêmes on ne peut pas
séparer les gens des idées qu'ils les
pardons à l'évolution raymond j'aimerais
avoir ton avis à la loi parce que tu as
un avis plus externe ce qui était pas
voilà n'est pas du giron tepa
journaliste voilà donc j'aimerais avoir
ton avis toit de téléspectateurs moi je
suis pas journaliste et moi j'ai juste
envie de dire à éric qu'il faut qu'il
continue éric mais plein de gens
intelligents pas que toi plein d'autres
gens intelligents pourquoi parce que
valérie je suis un peu la vie de valérie
et zemmour est très intelligent là il
s'enfermer dans une caricature dans un
personnage qui est complètement ouf
alors les gens qui ne veulent pas
l'écouter ne l'écouté pas mais ceux qui
veulent l'écouter
écoutons le écoutons le et signalons le
à chaque fois qu'il aura des dérives
signalons au csa il ya des lois il est
pas au dessus des lois
condamnons le à chaque fois qui sortira
une mère d'une connerie on sera on ne
lâchera pas si tu ne l'as pas fait si tu
te situes arrêtent de travailler avec
lui il écrire des livres sur youtube il
sera invité par des plateaux télé être
une excuse dieudonné ne parle plus
aujourd'hui dieudonné par finition des
messages à liège a refait pas les mots à
l'évasion et martial ait choisi mort est
venue finir je veux tu continues à
travailler avec lui pour que puisse être
nous en contradiction par rapport à ce
mec là c'est tout il ya des lois et puis
s'il doit être signalée maj oubliez ce
que je voulais dire c'est marrant mais
tout ça dans leur faut pas laisser faire
voilà bien sûr qu'elle y est ce que
voulait rassurant tout comme maxime est
ce que tu leur agir à tous d'en tuer des
femmes de renom je tente des rouies moi
je pense qu nettement à la la la chose
la plus intelligente à ses débuts c'est
avec lui alors il y aura comme comme ta
dire à quelqu'un pour le pour les mettre
à sa place je vais on va voir l'avis des
téléspectateurs après bien sûr tout le
monde attend de savoir où vous en êtes
vous eric naulleau
on va voir ce qu'en pensent ses
téléspectateurs oui à 41% non à 59%
c'est plutôt non mais c'est pas un pli
de sites pour le gabon voilà comment
c'est oui mais comme en 40
oui mais c'est pas je pensais que ça
allait être lancement l'arrangement sait
que ça va être 80
la vérité eric naulleau où vous en êtes
aujourd'hui
et qu'est ce que vous avez envie de
faire du coup la vérité moi j'ai une
position très simple sur ce sujet et de
cette position de laquelle je n'ai
jamais varié découle ma décision mais ma
position c'est que je ne suis pas juge
ce n'est pas à moi de dire si zemmour
violent la loi ou pas je ne suis pas
directeur de chaîne c'est pas à moi de
dire si zemmour doit être à l'antenne ou
pas je suis son contradicteur
or dans le discours qu'il a tenu samedi
j'ai trouvé 20 raison supplémentaire et
même plus que supplémentaire importante
encore plus importante de m'opposer à
lui parce que je trouve qu'il a
franchement déconner ans au moins cinq
ou six endroits comme on voulait pas
faire toutes les missions de zemmour et
naulleau là dessus je me suis attaché
seulement à deux points mais il ya
beaucoup d'autres points qui n'ont pas
seulement froissé qui m'ont choqué parce
que vraiment ils s'opposaient ce que ce
en quoi je crois profondément
donc je veux continuer à contrôler hier
et moi parce qu'il ya beaucoup plus de
raison de le contredire
après ce discours qu'avant voilà ma
position donc vous vous posez la
question mais quand même vous voulez
continuer je continuais mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya un avant et un après
eric dit la vérité est ce qu'à des gens
dans la rue parce que là je pose la
question que tous les téléspectateurs se
pose qui vous dise eric naulleau
vous ne pouvez plus continuer à
travailler qu'eric zemmour pourquoi vous
continuez à travailler avec lui est ce
qu'il ya des gens qui vous disent ça
c'est du 50-50 vraiment c'est à dire
qu'il ya des gens qui disent enfin
quelqu'un de gauche qui n'est pas
sectaire qu'ils acceptent de discuter
avec la partie adverse et il ya des gens
qui disent c'est scandaleux vous faites
équipe avec un type qui ne devrait pas
être arrêté
c'est du 50 50 c'est presque ce que
reflète le pourcentage des sondages un
beau cadeau que c'est assez c'est assez
partagés c'est assez partagés mais je
dois dire que comme je suis la cible à
la fois des défenseurs de zemmour et ses
détracteurs j'ai tendance à croire que
ma position est peut-être pas si bête
que ça
vous allez continuer à travailler à
chalon avec eric ça c'est ma décision
et bah écoutez si c'est votre décision
voilà en tout cas merci nous avons
demandé si vous nous avez demandé promis
vous avez demandé alors au ce soir
franchement moi je suis une pièce
rapportée dans
dans cette émission j'apprends à
connaître les gens il est des gens que
je connaissais avant comme comme
géraldine mais j'apprends à les
connaître à les apprécier et je trouve
que le tour de table qui s'est fait
était d'un très bon niveau qui a eu des
arguments pour y compte qu'ils étaient
vraiment très recevable et vraiment je
regrette pas d'avoir soumis cette
question à la aux jugements de mai de
mes collègues et ben merci et eric
naulleau